[تصفيق]
يحاول امين اختصار الوقت والمسافه لكن
حاله الازدحام والاقتضاض في العاصمه عمان
باتت مشهدا يتكرر كل يوم حالوا امين لا
يختلف عن حال خمسه ملايين شخص عجت بهم
عمان وما بين ضغط على البناء التحتيه
والخدمات ثمه امل بمساحه جديده للسكن بعد
اعلان الحكومه بناء مدينه حديثه تحاكي
احلام كثيرين كل يوم الصبح بس اجي اطلع
يعني الازمه دائما بتواجهني فعليا لو انه
المنطقه الاداريه يكون فيها كافه الطرق
سالك والامور تكون انا ما عندي مشكله طبعا
اكيد اني برحل تقع المدينه الجديده بين
عمان والزرقاء كمدن كبرى تعاني من الضغط
السكاني وتبدا اولى مراحلها عام 2025
وتنتهي في اقل من 10 سنوات بقدره
استيعابيه تصل الى
175,000 سنه ومع انتهاء المرحله الاخيره
عام 2050 يصل عدد سكان لمليون شخص يمكن
انشاء مدينه جديده
سيكون اقل كلفه من اصلاح البنى تحتيه
كامله في مدينه متسعه مثل العمال ثانيا
عمان توسعت بحيث انها يعني
احتلت مساحات كبرى بما فيها الاراضي
الزراعيه في وقت يرى كثيرون اولويه
الاتجاه لتطوير المدن الحاليه وبنيتها
التحتيه التي يعاني منها المواطن اضافه
للكثير من المشاريع المعلقه لابد من اعاده
قراءه اا الموقع واعاده قراءه ماذا نحن
نحتاج حقيقه لحل المشاكل التخطيطيه
والعمرانيه
للمدن الاردنيه وبلغه الارقام تصل تكلفه
المرحله الاولى للمدينه الجديده اكثر من
400 واربعين مليون دينار خصصتها الحكومه
من الموازنه العامه التخفيف من الضغط
السكاني اول ده في المدينه الجديده التي
ترى فيها الحكومه حلا اقتصاديا في ظل
ازمات يواجهها الاردن الا انها كانت براي
اخرين تحتاج لحلول اخرى تنجز في وقت سريع
وبتكلفه اقل بكثير عماد عضايا الى العربيه
عمان